hi everyone its Johanna here and today's
regard it's about getting rid of your
cellulite on your thighs and on your bum
so this workout is going to be high
intensity because what we want to do is
to break down and burn the fat off from
the thighs and your bum I want you to
get a pair of comfortable trainers
pumped up your energy it's going to be
challenging but it's going to be really
effective so let's start by doing some
warm-ups so let's start by doing some
easy warm-ups for a couple of minutes so
jump on the spot this warm-up is really
to get your boss is ready for some
intense workout and also to increase
your heart rate so just jog on the spot
and don't bring your knees up slightly
okay you should feel that you're already
incorporating your legs and your bum
which is what you want to target for
this workout video okay bring your knees
a little more so really try to bring it
as high as you possibly can in order to
keep your back straight so no-hunting
straight back and this up now bring your
legs back heels touching a path okay
keep that bouncing movement just always
bring your hardware down all right so
anything warm right now I'm feeling that
your heart rate is increasing slightly
get keep going alright now just slow it
down I will just do 20 normal sports as
part of our work okay so
we straight legs face in front and just
squat easy low Ella okay 20 times
okay this workout will involve lots of
squat ins and lots of jumping lunges to
really target the thighs and bum and to
really break and burn the fats that is
causing a so let's keep going
good job five more last two
so the first workout we'll be doing is
alternate squat so study middle squat
open elixir squat to the right side
close it and move on to the left side
okay so let's do travel on each side
ready let's go in the middle go right
squat and up
don't rush it really go as low as you
can and prove that you're targeting your
back and your thighs we're going to push
your luck all the way back and squat
good so push it back we push it back as
a coming to the site there you go who
should i good so use your left leg to
push it right to the center right it and
push it to the center good I'll be there
how are you feeling
can you already through the bad parts of
your class the front and your bum
working good jump going
and after this we will be doing some
jumping squats just increase intensity
last one one and one get and just match
up
the next worker jump squat so I want to
start by opening your legs what squat it
down
and jump okay so we'll be doing that or
ten times alright only ten jump squats
ready so let's apart squat and up down
up down good down and not for over there
all the way down good
three more do your little last look and
good job and now through the squats go
all the way down and pulse for 12 times
so keep your low and just put no pulse
and up that's it just small squats get
three this should really bring your eyes
and really really burn the satellites
off good keep going
toss it that's five plus three plus two
plus one
oh can you feel it burning now just
shake it off hug me through your workout
the next without lunges okay first
lunges ultimate lightest so start by
stepping back bring your right leg fold
large down and with your right leg
really push the right bum and go all the
way back so same thing also
to your left lunch down and who should
be done flick and come back up to a
seven okay oh gosh my breath
so let's do truck on your side hurry
let's go
lunch as low as you can push it back
good
just keep looking forward to keep your
balance get lunch push your back very
good job there you go remember to keep
your body 90 degrees body straight back
straight and just look forward it's
going to move good job keep going so
really use your core and your legs to
push yourself back push it back give
your back straight so I don't want to
see no hygiene forward or extend it too
far back all right
you should probably that let's go six
more on each side
well this is the first knowledge next
jumping lunges the Kuna workout but
trust me it's really going to work your
thighs and your bum to bring this
satellites off okay keep going
lunge all the way down push it back down
back down July last two
good job doing very well last one and
one more and just pause it
okay and push you like good
moving on to the next workout same thing
now I want you to jump and I'm going to
keep it really simple just dips on each
side okay so stand by
lunging on your right leg and burst into
your left leg okay that's one right
that's just six on your side that's to
keep going that's three that's four
that's wise last one that's six and keep
your back straight
good job okay now one more last lunges
we're just going to stay low hold it and
you know post it up okay so front leg
let's start with our right leg let's
parse it for ten seconds like what leg
straight go low and pulse it good
ah sweating and my muscles are so sore
right now keep going do you know five
more always came back straight last year
ah change that okay so same thing
white step looks ninety degrees down and
pulse it off
ready go
Jinbo you almost at the end of the
workout that's why last month
oh so now just shake it off and to end
this thighs legs workout to really burn
the sunlight off let's do a purpose or
good luck okay take it out take it
anyways and let's complete a purpose
ready
oh my grunting three two one let's go
down one okay to jump
get over there
keep going three more chop it off last
year
one more and good so don't stop right
away because now you just bring a heart
rate down slightly and just cool down if
you feel that you know what this workout
is not doing anything to me I challenge
you to do up to three sides so repeat
the whole swing again and do for three
sets
okay so just twist your lick gently just
to cool down okay that's no rush just to
bring your heart rate down alright and
just March don't forget to always
stretch after your workout so so put
yourself against the wall and just grab
your leg keep it back straight he's on
the bunk to stretch to stretch your
quads out okay if you can't you don't
have to support yourself can you hold it
really do the stretch change side okay
get inside the leg
good job that wasn't easy but that's the
whole point to make it intense so that
your workout is really effective now
just straightening entering off one leg
forward then your left leg and just
reach forward alright
the stretch along the right hand
fighting hand screams just reach down
change side
remember if you can do this three to
four times a week and always remember
that to burn your sunlight you need to
try to incorporate jumping exercises to
increase intensity
I'm absolutely dripping right now it's a
really sharp but intense workout and if
you can challenge yourself to two or
three sets per workout and you will see
result in four to six weeks time don't
forget to like this page share this
video try this workout with me let me
know what you think and do subscribe to
my fitness channel for more nutritional
and fitness videos
you